welcome to another episode of not too
deep with me your host grace and how big
the first we have a very exciting
episode as always Steve Zaragoza and Lee
Newton from the valley folk are here
with us the other two members of the
valley folk that we haven't had on yet
well technically they've been on in the
past but this is a very hard-hitting
interview to say the least guys I mean
if you don't have to believe this but
I'm pretty sure we spend about 20 solid
minutes reviewing the musical Cats and
you're gonna want to listen to every
goddamn second of it I wouldn't then we
talked about some other stuff too like
how they all like balance their mutual
like friendships and relationships and
work ethic and all that but the cat's
stuff is juicy to say the least enjoy
this episode of not too deep with Steve
and Lee or Steve as I sometimes call
them this episode is brought to you by
you guessed it Squarespace turn your
great idea into a reality with
Squarespace they make it easier than
ever to launch your passion project
whether you're showcasing your work or
selling products of any kind with
beautiful templates and the ability to
customize just about anything you can
easily make a beautiful website yourself
and if you do get stuck Squarespace is
24/7 award-winning customer support is
there to help go to squarespace.com
slash Grace for a free trial and when
you're ready to launch use the offer
code grace to save 10% off your first
purchase of a website or domain twitter
be angel baby
that's exactly what it is it has no
relevance to anything yes every time I
see it it's very synonymous with you
grace acquired when I was in college on
my sketch comedy team in college and we
needed props for this one sketch and we
went to Goodwill and bought this and
then sometime after college it moved
with me and I moved in Brooklyn like
five times and I lost like so many of my
like personal possessions but somehow
this thing made it through to every
has a name I'm sure don't just call it
this thing bubble baby baby come as a
bumble baby yes is it like an end
question I wonder if it was on gum
disease some goodies oh I love on goody
I love lily pad baby
what is the pie just an interpretation
of her the painting got acquired after
we were on our short lived actually what
we wondered on our set for the s5
situation we did with fullscreen and I
you know said I'm gonna ask her
something stupid and they probably won't
be able to deliver it I think I get it a
bumble baby as a Renaissance painting
and then they came back with this they
really did a great job help you okay so
a couple of things if there's a world
where cuz it's slightly it only slightly
bothers me but bother might be the wrong
word
yeah perturb confusing well I don't know
let me present it to you and then you
tell me what you think the right
phrasing is what if I acquired the the
remaining pieces of detail here for real
life baby solo caller what I'm a little
hot and everything
what like would you would would bumble
baby where those things I think so I
mean I really looked at this painting
like ever my you're welcome I didn't
realize that it's like it's playing with
its own feet being too coy and now I'm
do you love that they Renaissance did in
the sense that they're like no eyelashes
no is such a Renaissance thing of just
being like your pasty pale you never
seen some babies
ashes this kid has grown his lashes yeah
yeah you know why is there a one wearing
a thong up there you know baby sitting
in a giant butt like a flowers aphid oh
yeah I think so too because you see the
pad I saw a fire pit like Anne and Eddie
it's like a nice it's pretty great would
you ever wish that you were in on
Kandi's baby when you were growing up or
was a nun getting spit could you imagine
just need to comically smash it right
where the face a valley full calendar
20/20 but also here's the thing whatever
calendar Joe is just as a baby is gonna
fly off they're just gonna just get may
and you're like yeah I just can I tell
you what I want to be I want to be a
caterpillar baby that's coming like in a
cat oh yeah like a glow worm and I'm
coming out of like an apple yeah what
would Elliot and Joe be so we already
figured out Joe I mean Joe Joe I mean I
really do think Joe is like a cupid like
that's what I think it's like Oh
Elliot's like feather
his face is not into it I want a giant
swaddle him that's what I want to like
make him be a giant baby now what does
this mean psychologically let's talk
about I just enjoy being swaddled so yes
a dream human taco yes yeah I tried one
of those anxiety blankets oh I have a
weighted blanket yeah but I don't think
it is key it's very essential it is
worth the investment
let's make your own yeah call someone
out right now and throw them under the
bus are you ready for this I'm ready
this is my passive-aggressive way this
is my path listen to me okay listen this
isn't this is a declaration William
Haynes he's a good friend he's a he's a
fellow what would we say like a like a
Pierre he's appeared Holly hasn't he sat
on your lap he has sat on my lap time
and he so he lived with me for a little
bit okay and I acquired a wonderful
weighted blanket that I got from a
friend's sister's Kickstarter okay and I
like supported it and I felt really good
about it and so I gaily you're wasting
to me will will loved it comes home and
he's sitting on my couch and he would be
completely drowning in that blanket with
just his head hanging out of it looking
so peaceful and I was just like will why
do you love that blanket so much and
he's like it just feels like a hug and I
think if anybody needs a hug more than
anyone as well yeah I felt like in some
world I would
either by him one or maybe gift him that
okay cuz he's a good friend and he loves
it he loved it more than I did but I
really loved it too okay let's get that
out there just in case tube filter picks
this up oh yeah story hey who's that guy
keemstar is gonna hit me up but yes so
we'll moved out and then he like after
weeks of getting all of his like stuff
out of my house finally we like we we
like Alana and I finally had gotten the
will out and and then one day I'm just
kind of sitting around on the couch and
we've been doing some cleaning and she's
like where the hell is my weighted
blanket where's my anxiety blanket and
the first thing that pops into my head
is I bet will took it like this is but
he's not a thief he's not gonna steal
things and so one day he comes over this
is after weeks of him not being not
living at my place and not us not
hanging out and he comes over and we're
sitting around we're playing video games
and then I was just like will did you
take my anxiety blanket and without a
beat he goes hell yeah is this a moment
for me to be like well I was like why
did you take my blanket he's like I love
it I just didn't want to talk about it
anymore because he knew it would lead to
maybe me asking for it back so he just
kept like changing the subject but
literally yeah literally like if you
step back from our friendship and
everything it just like we'll just stole
and in get a blanket from my home
without you and like I let him like be
in my house without my actively use the
blanket in front of him ever I mean I
did he assumed oh you don't use it so
it's gonna go to waste and why would you
know what they say about assuming you're
right a hundred times I mean he yeah I
wouldn't put it I would be on I mean I
didn't sleep with it but it was not
easily
$130 on a tape ordered actually like the
wrong size I got so mad it's a little
it's small baby it's very small these
expensive small so that's I assume
that's gotta be full size because I
tried one on tried went on I Martin's
house one day and I never felt safer
they're so nice yeah I don't know why I
always say that he's my cuz he's so big
he's like Abby's like do Swedish you
know like dumb he's just this beautiful
weighted blanket but I also know that
that is how I'm gonna go like I'm hands
and it's not even there like you know
when Gandalf like touches Frodo's hand
story so much because he's like I look
like a monster
but he one time we were like joking
because I couldn't open up this jar like
I could not open it up and I was like
well get over here loves your hands you
got to do this and literally he like it
goes to do it he's like I can't do it I
was like put your back into it he
shatters yeah hey did he smash it in his
hands like well pickles are
like you were in distress oh my god and
then I am how do we market this hand
we'll just like like slowly slip it into
your hair one night and then he'll just
crush your eye - what's the current
status of this no feud that is brewing
well it's it's me I wouldn't call it a
feud simply because of the fact that
that was the only discussion well and I
had I was like did you take my bucket
hell yeah and then I was like you can't
do that and then it ended this is my
this is my official calling will out for
my weighted blanket William Haynes you
stole my weighted blanket and I just
want you to know that you should keep
the damn blanket because I love you and
it ends early would have gifted it to
you anyway don't steal [ __ ] from my
house well what else do you think he's
taken that's what it's not a bad no I
mean obviously my members they're taking
inventory your memory does suck because
you will a Stevie does this thing where
he will find something in his house mate
let me give you a little insight into
babies Steve or like young Steve there
used to be in our garage like this like
box that would just like you know we
throw all the old toys in it yeah that
we weren't loving and playing with in
the house and so I would just be playing
with toys in the house and then I'd be
like man I remember I had this like
really cool thing that I really loved I
wonder where that is I'd go to like my
mom and be like mom where's that really
cool thing that I really liked and she'd
be like it's probably in that box of
toys in the garage and so I'd take the
box of toys I would just like dump it
upside down in the garage and it was
just like oh man and I come back into
the house of like Oh
these old toys that my mom like probably
like couldn't wait to like throw in the
office yeah we were I did your guys's
podcast the other week and when we were
leaving we put it out on the way out
you're like Steve said he was gonna take
this he's never gonna take this it was
like a pop pan I know that you called
yourself out because she you're like hey
we only need this one do one take this
one home I don't know what she was
thinking I don't know honestly I don't
know what shoes
no no no it was like so a lot of like
brought this like pan set from our yes
that I just bought like weeks prior
because we needed some pans for cooking
and such like cookie sheets doing a
sketch with cookies in it and I asked
Alana cuz we're really close to the
office and I was like could you please
bring it to the office interested of
course she brings it and it's a it's a
rat it's still shrink-wrap these two
pans yes big ones small and I was like I
rip it open I'm like okay we only need
the small one so I was like Alana we
just take this big one home and she's
like no no just keep them together and
then bring them both home and I was like
all of us looked at her like that's
never gonna happen
I need you no I just need you to know
that like I'm not gonna break I just
love you I love you I'm not I just
doesn't work that way like this is what
you're getting uni was like you just
like she didn't she fought it she fought
it we should take it oh yeah she was
like just bring it home and I was like
Alana I don't need this keep them
together and I was like this is the I
you will never see this again I was like
you will net these will never go home
men check out that way to get
you will watch it happen he will
literally be like all right guys I'm
gone I mean our job is like we get in it
we pile into the office anytime between
like 9:00 a.m. and 2:00 p.m.
yeah and it's like you know when's once
we're all there then we shoot all the
things that we are planning on shooting
and so it's just like this come in and
like chill and write and do these little
explosion of energy and like we're alive
let's do this and then by like 5 o'clock
you're like I don't want to be here yeah
yeah tired of all of you yeah Elia and
Joe about this like that's how you guys
operate it on SourceFed which always
blew my mind I came in to like guess
with you guys I was just like this is a
[ __ ] well-oiled machine I know it's
6:00 a.m. every day the way they did we
none of us wanted to come in at 6 a.m.
every day like that conditioned you guys
so now you still even though you're
independent and doing your own thing
that are you still working that capacity
mentally yeah because it always felt
like we're I mean at least I always felt
like I was more productive as like a
early riser or sorter though and I am a
person that like turns in the script at
2:00 a.m. yeah every time it's like a
2:00 a.m. that's and we've even like
I've done sleep studies like back in
college yeah and I am a there's morning
out others a night owl and morning larks
and like never actually literally you
cannot change the brain chemistry you
really shouldn't do it but like there is
literally like a brain chemistry thing
of like what you're more like conducive
to work in whoa and my life is literally
that per se that ya know it's truly
believe that whatever programming we
have in our brains is reprogrammable you
just like it is hard it's not easy
yes you don't know I've never been a
morning person I've never I've tried
be really trying oh yeah yeah two years
I think every day but as soon as I had
the opportunity to not do that college
like I avoided it yeah I'm like you
where I get like late night brain energy
I would literally write down notes like
the thing that we were just recently it
was like a note at 2 a.m. where I was
like click click click yeah down and I
would have in any other capacity if I
didn't have to wake up I would have
literally gotten up yeah done it and
that's always how it has been my best
sketches my best ideas my bus everything
has come at the at morn a.m. well I
wouldn't I don't know I've tried it
sorted even the source but it was like 6
a.m. and by 10 o'clock I did good
morning every always that I don't know
why always has been
ya know I'm with you cuz Hannah is like
a super morning person and then I like
wake up at the time that I want to wake
up whenever it is and then I checked her
Instagram story and she's had a full day
three hours coffee shop and then I get
like jealous of that but then like when
the Sun sets I feel like that's my day
starting hey I love the Magic Hour so
much and I feel so much more creative
because it's just yeah there is
something really nice about like waking
up before anybody else is up and the
trip before traffic gets crazy
I've even experienced it like when you
go camping something like a circadian
rhythms totally shift and you're like
it's 6:00 a.m.
circadian mister I believe the brain can
shift I'm sorry
I think that's proven I think to a
degree but I think emotionally like the
emotional connection that you have city
in farts no no it's a it's it's some
kitty in part some Kitty does that one
I'm Gideon like we're two hours in and
they're still introducing it's it's
insane this is a really flex our social
media influences that we got free
tickets to cats years ago and it was me
and Mae Murray and Tyler Oakley oh my
god and I knew it was a crazy musical
but I had no idea that it scene had any
of you seen it had had it when I was
younger and my stepmom my dad's place
well is there like visitation one
weekend I was like bored and everyone
was kind of doing their own thing and my
stepmom had a VHS of cats now it's like
fourth grade and I put it in and I
started watching I was like I don't know
what the [ __ ] is going on yeah but you
feel like it's not for you when you're a
kid watching that's you're like this is
an adult thing I'm gonna be sexual about
this and scary and I don't like yes very
for sure I saw a Fresno production of
cats want to keep that under Resident
the thing that is the most beautiful and
it might have formed a real pocket of my
brain
speaking of forming it literally none of
the male guys their own spandex and none
of them had dance belts so I was like an
11 12 year old the only thing I could
think of was just like this giant moose
knuckles
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
yeah we we actually uh I knock over [ __ ]
I know I knew it would happen and I'm
sorry the weirdest thing about cats
though is like if you really like break
down like what what it's about
it's like oh I mean I think I'm like
class you know just trichotomy well in a
disjointed way I think it's like TS
Eliot or something like does anybody
know like I mean I know it's either TS
Eliot or someone wrote this book about
cats yeah it's basically like poems
about cats something like that and then
they adapted that book into a musical
but I guess the estate was like in order
to make this into a musical like you
cannot change any of the words you can't
change any of the wording and so they
yeah so basically it's like if you're
really listening to the music like
barely any of it rhymes oh yeah it
doesn't make any sense though it's just
it literally is cats just introducing
themselves for an entire finally you get
this like the Grizabella cat which sings
memory which is like beautiful song I'm
just waiting for that song and then what
happens is is I guess it's like old
Deuteronomy which who I love by yeah
because during the intermission he just
sits on stage someone gave me mushrooms
does anybody else see him but he's I
love it and then I was like I was really
like focusing on old dude is the second
time I've seen it but I was just like I
was like I couldn't play any of these
[ __ ] cats you know they're just like
these are so nice and they're just like
you have their light on their feet and
they're
beautiful dancers I think you're giving
yourself enough credit but old
Deuteronomy is just like he's he's
supposed to be old and so all the cats
kind of like help him around and then he
sits for like most of the show yeah and
then there's like a alien spaceship or
something else this is what it is okay
old Deuteronomy has the ability to
basically choose a cat right to move on
to deaf essentially so there's cat
whatever mr. Webber it was really
distracting when we went and saw it
because there's one cat that we saw in
the playbill name like Marmee or
something and then she came out she
looked exactly like me this is basically
your name she's just like frazzled red
hair yeah then we got to meet the cat's
after the show graduations I got to meet
a little sweet instagrams out of it and
some merch and then I got it once I was
single grace and I got drunk and I went
and I hooked up with someone I'm not
I'm not an idiot this is at least 38
dollars worth of t-shirt yeah but I will
say so it's love should talk about this
show but it's like it's a classic it's
like the first time they did like you
have to see it it's so unbelievable I
mean it's just I started the Pantages
yeah when I was a sod in New York yeah
that's how much one was better I mean I
would contend the Fresno yeah I thought
I thought Rumble teaser
from Thomas I think it's like there's
these two there's these two characters
that come out and one of them is called
rubble teaser and they dance together
and they just talk about how they're
like full of mischief and [ __ ] oh yeah
yeah and they're like clearly like dance
partner yeah they're the mischievous
yeah aegis performance of that instead
but mr. Mistoffelees who is like the
most magical he's yeah yeah and with his
jacket that like lights up and like he
does apparently one of the most
complicated dances in like Broadway
really yeah and so you're watching him
just spinning around on the stage and
it's just like a spectacle of like
amazing yeah were you doing oh very oh
you feel so high right but like if you
do like that whoa yeah a cats are like
in them in the roads and they're like
coming up we're gonna take a quick break
when we get back we have more with this
episode of not too deep is brought to
you by my dear friends over at 3rd love
with more than 70 sizes including their
signature half cup sizes third love
designs bras with breast size and shape
in mind for a perfect fit and premium
feel just answer a few simple questions
via third loves fit finder quiz to find
your perfect fit in 60 seconds then
thanks to third loves 100% fit guarantee
you can wear wash and put your bra to
the test for 60 days and if you don't
love it you can return it and third
level wash it and donate it to a woman
in need this is hands-down the most
comfortable bra your own with straps
that won't slip tagless labels and
lightweight super thin memory foam cups
you guys know me I talk about sports
bras as if I have some sort of
investment in the sports bra community
I love comfort and these bras are
actually the most comfortable actual
bras I own
make me feel like an actual woman and
not just like wannabe soccer player so
highly recommend third love knows
there's a perfect bra for everyone so
right now they're offering you beautiful
listeners 15% off your first order go to
third love comm slash Grace now to find
your perfect fitting bra and get 15% off
your first purchase that's third
love.com slash grace for 15% off today
you would not believe that this episode
of not too deep is sponsored by um
Squarespace you got it you know that
turn your dream into a reality with
Squarespace they make it easier than
ever to launch your passion project
whether you're looking to start a new
business showcase your work published
content sell your products or more
Squarespace is the tool for you with
beautiful templates created by
world-class designers and the ability to
customize just about anything with a few
clicks you can easily make a beautiful
website yourself
Squarespace is powerful ecommerce
functionality lets you sell anything
online with analytics they help you grow
your site in real time and everything is
optimized for mobile right out of the
box there's nothing to patch or upgrade
ever thank God because I don't know what
that means buying domains is simple and
you'll get the help you need with
Squarespace is 24/7 award-winning
customer support
Squarespace empowers millions of people
from designers to lawyers artists to
gamers even restaurants and gyms to turn
great ideas into something real head to
squarespace.com slash grace for a free
trial and when you're ready to launch
use the offer code grace to save 10% off
your first purchase of a website or
domain that squarespace.com slash grace
offer code grace I remember just being
like whoa over and over and over and you
but it's like we're in the 2000s now
right and then we're and you're watching
these people on stage and they're just
like the things that they're doing and
saying yeah and it's just people so like
rich people purport like they purported
it like it literally is that that I what
I'm thinking about like they like they
made it continue but definitely Diane
and Carol came home and really
and then there was these it was me just
and he was like nighttime dancer you and
did you guys both go to theater school
you have to imagine you're watching
these people ride around ridiculously
and they're like but they all went to
school and studied all I'm thinking
about this well I'm like looking at
these actors faces while they're jumping
around they're like what what makes you
like choose to do cats and like there's
so many productions going on at one time
in LA and New York and Paris are like
you know there is that one a hole in the
back that like it's fully Mistoffelees
from like 8 a.m. things off the edges
oh don't no don't talk to Daniel he
doesn't full Mistoffelees right now oh
no so don't call him Daniel yeah but
it's like the reason that you like it's
like what you're seeing on the stage is
like the reason why drama kids are like
made fun of yeah oh yeah it seems like
it's like taking way juicy dogs I'm
serious about this Steve let's write it
I don't know why dogs hasn't happened 30
minutes long I mean it's gonna be better
Grace has questions Steve we have a
mansard a single question of Messi no
what would be your dream role for you
guys I mean we kind of hurts to use oh
wow specifically deuteronomy's not my
dream role but I dream of use of
musicals oh it's tough I I mean it's
tough because all the women ones are
always very fragile and have like yeah
gigantic voices which I do not so I feel
like I would have to literally just be
something what's like a legally insane
side part
handle like grease like yeah
you did that in high school it was awful
it was honestly one of my mother who is
says the nicest things about everything
walked away being like you were in a
show I mean I just know that there's
like theater people that are listening
to this right now that I like properly
any of the wicked any if I could sing
properly yeah hypothetically amazing
voice that can yet fit into any role
hypothetically and wicked yeah and all
that madness yeah there we go no good
witch or bad way Holly said so that's
the far superior role I think there
there are two for me okay that our dream
roles one of them has always been
Seymour in Little Shop of Horrors you be
great so good as elder price that's the
other one yeah yeah yeah he's so good
you'd be great yeah so just ask me to do
like a like a like a version of it in a
you to be thing yeah and I was like 100
percent would you I can't sing at all
but we're saying if you could because I
get to be the good the bad which can do
that we're trying to think oh I haven't
seen it but I'm sure it's fun Legally
Blonde yeah I actually did that in like
in and I we did like excerpts of it in
college and stuff and so I did really
cute this do by them yeah really yeah it
was like what I mean it was later in
college okay and then the Spelling Bee
that's a really good one to us I've
never seen that that's a really really
that I would there's like parts in there
that you're like oh I love that I would
100% want to be in that Arrested
Development musical that like y'all they
keep going back to like Captain Hook the
musical and every single time I think
it's I think it's both of them George or
George my Arab not George senior but
who's what it was Jason Bateman's
yeah but every time we see it I want to
write out the full musical like every
time I see it I want to be like surely
I'm sure my friends Jimmy um last year
and he's a brilliant mind boy but he
literally took the one-woman play from
lala land and he wrote it all out it was
like so long Boulder City
I wouldn't like went to New York like oh
and he's so he's such a feral performer
and he's such a wild man his mind is so
brilliant that he just did a drag
version of Emma Stone and so on Boulder
City anyway also in it plays to every
single thing that you think because he
watched that shown you're like that's a
horrible
that's a horrible there's no way you
could get cast in a huge movie after
that no but he does all of it like he
like those so he goes into the full
insanity of it all and it was brilliant
and every time I see I'm like oh that's
one we I had one but we just didn't have
the production time and it was a
Christmas musical and it was very bad
like very bad I got to write musical he
things all the time SourceFed I did a
Benjamin Franklin time job musical and
Jon Cozart was like Nikola Tesla
oh no no Bree was Nikola Tesla Tesla jon
cozart was oh maybe like the telephone
Alexander Graham Bell or said I can't
remember but sounds great no it was
Hamilton he was Hamilton yeah because it
was like Hamilton was coming for Ben
Franklin Franklin want to make a musical
like Hamilton so I got like Meghan
tonjes and I got like all these cool
students optics in it and I got to write
like I actually wrote it from here I end
up like the music the lyrics everything
it was so fun I had a great time I just
like it's just like a time concern there
grace if that's what you want well maybe
the valiant musical give the people what
they want
Elliott does not sing karaoke song one
time he's like singing is like the one
thing I don't know this is true one time
we were all singing along and we heard
him and literally all of a sudden you
stop here like a baby
probably 75 times with us and has never
said he's like I don't have a son so I
don't do karaoke it's like karaoke is
not supposed to be for only people that
equaliser yeah it's one of those things
were like I bet if we got him into one
of those like room karaoke things I'm
telling you like we get him a little
liquored up it's like pick a Weezer song
okay let's do at a Weezer's I'm in the
Sun just here yeah beautiful I like my
hash Piper's love it is it called hash
Piper half pipe
I'm learning so much always in the last
thing I'm so sorry I thought it was
actually noticed a direct eye contact
that he made when Elliott brought up
Weezer you literally like you literally
were like he was like I'd like to talk
about the Weezer album I went I thought
it was for sure a joke Mike Horstman
when he first started telling me how
much he likes Weezer this is a funny bit
that you do yeah no he's literally
Florida boy like in his bones
yeah I thought I was trash real nice
that when you meet someone that makes
you feel like a little rap sigh I've
said it before and I'll say it again you
gotta be less trash no I'm in the triage
though so I'm the trash one in mind yeah
you didn't go to college
I didn't finish college a little bit
about this is there the way you guys
work is there like a safe word when
things go too far we wanted one okay we
I was just saying this we've wanted one
like for instance when like Steve will
go too hard on a bit and it will make
someone angry like we just experienced
when Elliot
on a podcast and there's been times he's
done stuff with me that I want to just
punch him in the face
and I'm positive I've done stuff where
the boys are like killer now so we're
just making good content but we've had
one that we've been like we should have
a safe word but like is that word that
no matter what we don't need no way do
you like the harbor anger I think here's
what we do we keep our set pretty closed
it's like the four of us and Kevin were
the four of us and Kevin and Kade right
or and it's like we're just in this
circle of trust it's like anything we
say in this room anything we do in this
room yeah if it's like if it makes
someone uncomfortable if someone's
pissed off then they have the right to
be like it doesn't go in we do have that
unwritten thing we just have we
need a safe word because if we had a
safe word it would like instantly kill
that bad yeah okay well and you would
know that it actually cuz I think there
has been moments where we have 100% like
upset each other like without exact
words in such close quarters for how
long it's just inevitable and we are
like for lack of a better word like a
mesh like we are like yeah it is
it's gross yes but there's also that
like the the audience isn't quite sure
like the turn signal thing abridged
Elliot like we're on our podcast on the
valley cast we all bring up subjects
right and we all we were all doing these
subjects and Jo ran to go get lottery
tickets cuz that was and then so Elliot
because so my topic is about turn
signals and I said can I go with Jo I
want to leave it needed to play a turn
signal sound over and over and over
here's the thing Elliot seems incredibly
upset and he seems like he's done and
over enemy said I'll leave and he'll do
all this [ __ ] but then when we're done
he's like that was great I loved I love
everybody and then the audience like
there was this there was this one
comment on the video where like someone
wrote out this whole thing that was just
like okay here's why Elliot should have
calmed down Steve was just being this
and I can't believe the audience can't
really tell yeah I mean when the bet
goes honestly when we're actually angry
at each other yeah what you'll get is is
like someone is just more quiet than the
other person oh yeah you want even get a
bit no you won't get a reaction right
Elliot is obviously and we like do like
a weird disease where it's like let's go
for a walk or let's talk this out yeah
that's like really is that did you quite
and I still think we need a source say
for it no we don't need it can it
Spiller
because it's been a year right yeah 20
years and then it's been 7 years of
being like close friends yeah yeah so it
is it is fully that like it's there's
nothing I don't know we used to we used
to all be in the same room years ago for
years and then yeah kind of like
everyone went their separate ways and we
still kept in touch but then like we
came right back into the being all
around each other again yeah yeah this
whole year we've been doing the valley
folk and it's just been like oh yeah now
I remember
you know how's it been and we talk to
Jonah Leah about this too like in the
last year what's been like the biggest
learning curve for you guys I don't want
to be a part of a lot of Twitter
questions and a lot of them are about
like working with your friends and like
how did that we I I would say I'll speak
for Steve on this we do have fun ever
like it's a blast every single day we're
laughing we're making each other laugh
it is so much fun there's you know other
realm in which I would want to be doing
this kind it's like and I do realize
like I have other friends and I'll hang
out with them and and I realize like the
reason why I gravitate so much towards
these boys is because we our main goal
is honestly to make someone to make each
other laugh and we're so on the same
page with our sins we are it's so weird
and so it's a very weird thing to
experience with other like performers
and whatever but the big the biggest
learning curve has been in business
we're not were creative know it we're
idiots when it comes to literally you
guys are doing it Bill underneath and we
all were like when do we see if it
wasn't for Joe I feel he would have and
he put out the fires and yeah he is a
leader he always has exuded leadership
qualities but we literally are like
deferring ji-ho
we have this guy that works next door to
us and it just so happens his main
office is in its right neck and we all
with our writers room and so we're in
here going like and it's like we just
Joe will get a text and it'll just be
like please please I mean we can say
kind of but he like he tests children's
like intellect and like like basically
he's testing ADHD kids and child
psychologists them to be able to pay
attention and we're in them behavior
they're certainly going to there there's
also like right under us is like a
doctor
and we're just like and we're stomping
our feet and we're just like running and
Joe's kid is there and he's running the
office and throwing toys at the wall and
it's just like slamming like in the same
complex as our build as our office
there's also this like massage place so
so but I was looking at cuz my back was
hurting really bad the other day and I
was like maybe I'll go get it like a
massage at this place and we haven't
done it and they were like offering us a
discount for being like 10 minutes of
the building whatever and so I was like
I was looking into it on Yelp and like
almost every review was like massage is
great
you could hear every step we should be
out in the field somewhere like wow they
are what we do right and they're like in
a part of our work we were reading
through a script the other day and part
of it was like us screaming don't stop
believin
yeah defense do we have no with that
yeah it's like this is our job but it's
like this guy's like helping kids but I
will say in regards to like working with
your friends and stuff I feel like it's
it's probably a bad idea
like just I'm just being real I mean
like you know but your situation is
unique I think you guys have all worked
together in the past
yeah the thing like we weren't friends
before we were thrown into this room
together right so we like developed a
friendship based around this type of
work so it kind of like works out that
way
yeah obviously there's like I mean we
are we are all four of us married
essentially yeah we are sharing this
business if anything happens we're all
equally screwed we have this you know we
have this this obligation to kind of
like be there for each other sure but
it's like I mean look at the end of the
day we're making like fun videos and
we're having fun as friends but it's
like the stresses of that are very real
as you know and as a lot of people know
the stresses of life are real and you
know it's hard to be in a situation
where you're like piled with stress and
you're also like maybe stuffs happening
in your personal life and then like all
the stuffs happening and then it's like
now sit on a couch and be funny with
these people who are like yeah I know
who also are feeling the same way
stressed out in their lives you know
balancing that yeah yeah and I think the
at SourceFed we we always had someone
who is like there was always like a
person in charge and then there was like
a producer someone you know yeah it's
really one of those things when anyone
listens to we're all in charge of each
other and we're all on equal ground and
it's like difficult to kind of like
maintain that as a professional yeah cuz
it's like how how do we even find yeah
that's true yeah yeah I mean it's got
it's got to be a huge learning curve
because it's literally you're building
something out of nothing and then you're
all
hoping for the best but no I think it's
to managing like knowing your
limitations and being like I can't do
the business side that really is a big
part of it and being like I don't know
like anytime and I go into that channel
at all I'm like I will ruin something I
will try my best but I promise you have
things will get deleted
Paige it'll I did it on my phone and I'm
somehow I'm like a different valley folk
folk account has like Lee's name on it
is important to note that as far as our
friendships go 100% we are able to be
ourselves like oh that is so true we
it's really a rare thing I mean like you
guys are all very non-judgmental people
just to you guys
it seems like from the outside that it's
just a group of people that all want the
same thing
yeah yeah respect each other and I do we
all want the same thing we all like we
all want to make each other laugh and we
all do make each other laugh and
laughter such an important part of - one
of our lives but it's just this like
symbiotic kind of like yeah it is a very
weird it just makes it easier you know
especially since you know I mean there
are people who work at jobs that are
like hiding who they really are
I'm afraid to let those walls down
around people and become friends with
coworkers but it really is such a weight
off of your shoulder when you meet
people who you can truly be yourself and
make like it may be better or worse yeah
that's the truth is yeah we have I don't
think any of us hold anything back
I don't certainly don't and it seems
like you all genuinely care for each
other than if one who comes in with like
an outside problem yeah yeah help you I
mean if I had to put them all in an
order of who I care about more
well Joe first because he has a kid
Kevin first okay we're gonna take
another quick break and we get back
we're gonna get into these Twitter
question this episode of not too deep is
brought to you by
hum-hum nutrition is all about making
you look and feel your best each
specific supplement packs a combo of
potent ingredients designed for specific
aims like clear skin boosted energy or
fuller hair and is backed by clinical
results hum focuses on preventing
concerns and long-term care and repair
not damage control and covering up their
inside out approach to beauty goes
beyond a skin care regimen alone to give
you great results
hums products are sustainably sourced
non-gmo and free of soy gluten
artificial colors and preservatives plus
lots of vegan options try supplements
like the daily cleanse hair sweet hair
growth gummies uber energy and more if
you aren't sure what you need go to humm
nutrition calm slash get underscore
started to take a quiz and get
personalized recommendations from humm's
team of registered dieticians to make
things even easier hum offers a monthly
vitamin subscription that's affordable
flexible and convenient I mean hair
sweet hair growth gummies one you know I
love a gummy vitamin too you know I need
to grow my hair ox my extensions have
ravished my scalp uncontrollably so
three this is my best case scenario I'm
all for it go to home nutrition comm
slash get underscore started for
personalized recommendations and get 20%
off your purchase with code grace that's
huh mat nutrition calm slash get
underscore started and code grace this
episode of not too deep is brought to
you by Lisa Lisa believes that a bed is
more than just a place to sleep it's a
place for relaxation and rest and they
believe that everybody has the right to
rest that's every body has the right to
rest that's why they make
- awesome mattresses plus accessories
and bases to give your body the deep
rest it needs the all foam Lisa mattress
is new and improved including cooling LS
a 200 foam for enhanced pressure relief
for side sleepers that's me
their superior hybrid mattress is the
perfect combination of foam and spring
for pressure relief and edge to edge
support Lisa's mission is to provide a
better night's sleep for every body and
from day one at Lisa's set out to create
a company with heart that's why they
donate one mattress for every 10 they
sell to organizations that work in
causes like foster care prevention to
date they've donated more than 32
thousand mattresses through more than
1,000 nonprofits I have one of their
mattresses it is absolutely wonderful
it's just I mean I barely sleep and this
thing really helps me get there Plus
knowing that you're sleeping on
something that donates to a good cause
is you know it really helps you fall
asleep knowing that the world isn't as
terrible as you think it is get 15% off
your entire order at Lisa comm / grace
and use promo code grace that's l ee s
a.com slash grace promo code grace okay
I'm gonna ask you guys before we get
into the Twitter questions the two
questions asked every single guest
that's on the podcast I'm ready
and then the first is who alive or dead
would you most want to throw cold
spaghetti at Joe had a very tough time
in saying this oh no I know it I mean
like everyone I'm sure says Hitler it's
been done I'm sure buy a cold spaghetti
doesn't have to be an imposing know it
can be so no but if it's like I'm
thinking my cold spaghetti is very like
like hard and like in a ball it's been
there for a couple days so it's it's a
it's a wob I've been reading a lot about
Picasso and what an [ __ ] he was so it
probably would be Pablo Picasso okay I
think it's the first time we've ever had
that answer you know I would do I would
throw cold spaghetti at Andy Kaufman
be like yeah beautiful
oh that's why I went as joe said it
would be the guy that's been dumping in
the dumpster next to you guys the trash
has made its way into the parking spot
seeing how you guys are may be operating
in your relationships with other people
in your space yeah
what do you think is worse cold
spaghetti in the face or pie in the face
well pie hurts I think pies is both the
same pressure and it's not very hard
I guess things get II could get
everywhere yeah for some reason to get
yeah cuz you could get those noodles
stuck in your hair to get pied to get
sketti that's a big deal it can it be
living to throw spaghetti at Paul
Reubens
okay yeah that's a great way really not
gonna like that I feel like she'd have
some fun with it
okay the other question is to tell us
your worst pants shooting story or close
call we can only use three words or
phrases
small phrases like mine is college
jogging front lawn and that's it that's
it okay okay
Italian food is that one word you can do
smoke okay yeah tallien food long car
drive and a lot of stairs stairs
sta
that wiggle I mean it's like how do you
it's like imagine four flights of stairs
no and you're ready go brakes one from
the other Christmas Santa into it no
Christmas sorbitol what is that it is a
it is a sugar alcohol substitute
[Music]
that we didn't know sugar substitute in
very delicious cookies too many cookies
I will say that while in the car on my
story not to break the form go for it
just really quick while in the car I
just it got to the point where I just
had to admit to everyone no I
this was very recent for me yeah because
I did last Christmas I gave you my fart
no it was I ate too many of them and
then made sugar alcohols apparently this
is like put what's it called and
sorbitol okay my child was in the ER kg8
sugarfree gummy bears no my sister made
these cookies because she was like
trying to avoid sugar just you see via
like all the other looks we all she's
stevia and I'm like Stevie doesn't make
you shoot your pants yeah yeah we know
but literally it was one of those were
like I was so ill I picked everything
everything came up but I was so ill from
it and then I literally went into the
bathroom and I was like this is
happening all of it because you're
puking and so you can't focus on
anything I'm sorry I was like this is
happening and my angel of a husband came
in literally like dead lifted me into
the bathtub
[Laughter]
like these the pants might have to go
and they're like you know like those
comfy pants are feeling like they might
have to go and that's what wrecked me
not that I completely believe at
Christmastime in the bath with you and
you wash them out watch them and it's
like what then you gonna get a new
washer/dryer it was a nightmare and
honestly since that day if there's like
a sugar-free anything I mean what's in
this I would be so so on it I don't
think I've had anything like it since
honestly I've been like that'll shake
that's I'm like committing that word to
memory to serve atop mallet on any of
those tall bad bad news bears no and
apparently I wasn't the only one that
like had bad news like I hurled my
mother's like 6-3 in like music
powerlifting now so he was like it
wrecked me oh that's funny I forgot to
mention that so Diane does a lot of our
research on her guests before like give
me like all these cards and one of the
things that she wrote about you Lee I
said she has a brother or sister and
brother is Loki hot musician yeah I mean
I've heard it my entire life he's a he's
a full-blown babe we got a full-blown
babe and he's a great musician - he's
amazing sleeping wolf they're amazing
band cool but it is one of those were my
entire life I've heard of like
yeah I know he was like a model he's
like bang your friends I'm positive oh I
don't know
he's a nice boy he's a he's also got a
kindness heart of anyone I have no
period he was also sandwiching between
two sisters Leon he's wrecked wait he's
wrecked as far as like emotion goes but
um I know for a fact that like I had
friends that came over all the time just
like can I come over there was always
that thing I know I'm positive that they
were like so like sick a fan can't wait
to deep dive on the Instagram okay why
haven't you guys started writing a
muppet movie of your own yet I mean I
it's a dream it is a dream it's a dream
for us we have puppet cast members right
that Steve and I were very diligent
about having how did they come about we
want we want a puppet and we we it was
something that we talked about a lot
about having them and creating that lore
and creating that world of like that and
then Steve found these baby angels and
we were like oh my god were so in love
with them online they were one-of-a-kind
puppets that this guy was building and
he was only selling one of each of these
guys and then after we acquired them we
were like okay now we need to like own
these guys we we officially owns cousin
well and it's a really funny like
because he knows the lore of it so much
like of the Muppet world of like how
difficult it is to like actually get
things passed they throw things and like
so I think we we both did that thing we
were like we're just gonna make our own
yeah I mean I just always wanted to I
mean back in the SourceFed days I
brought in source Fred
and and I just like I can't help but
bring puppets into acting I'm working on
Street surgery so they can see what
everyone else is thinking yeah I mean we
had all these show ideas in the
beginning when we were kind of like
crunching ideas for shows and one of
them was like something where it's like
it takes place in a puppet world every
once in a while one of us would like
come in and like sing with one of them
like we'd have like these things and
it's still kind of in the pipeline but I
mean a movie about scuzz or to know if
there is a cheese called Zaragoza what
kind of cheese would it be that's a
really oh I think it would be honestly I
would have to think about my favorite
cheese which is moot City huh I do like
you the cheese what is it I mean it was
very much a dad thing that he would like
come in and be like hey you know what I
think I've got it I've got it my cheese
the Zaragoza cheese would be fresh
mozzarella would like a little bit of
cinnamon and sugar in it just just a pit
disgusting I think you I think your your
Zaragoza cheese would be like a creamier
manchego Oh
or maybe like a little some Spanish yeah
that's what I'm saying okay you're gonna
like options yeah someone's only what is
it like making trivia bidet I love that
show so much I at the very beginning was
like I will never do that Shelley I will
I was like I will never do this show
people like do it is all shot is very
shocking about it I was like diddly come
up with this cuz yeah and they were
absolutely not no she just refuses to do
it recently they were like what are you
gonna do it you deserve to do in those
like Nonna's Sajak to spin the wheel you
know Sajak spins the wheel
no I'm positive no but it is like I love
hosting it so much and you definitely
become something that I truly like yeah
I'm on board with now but I and we just
have Whitney more on it actually please
she's so delightful she's like little
yes laughter and just she's petals of
flowers but she 100% solidified why I
can't do it because I I was in the room
I was the only one in the room usually
Jose down below operating the pad a one
time Elliot wasn't he's not allowed to
do it again I'd be like 100 percent hurt
someone listen it's a powerful bidet you
go over it you're like mm-hmm well it
has like it's like a cartoon dial that's
like it turns red and if you turn it get
ready
I mean there won't be a dirty particle
anyway yeah really it would yeah but uh
but Joey usually operates it but with
Whitney I was like of course in order to
like I was like oh I'm gonna up like
it's just me and her in the room and I
think even Kevin was like very far back
and it was yeah just like you know
respectful but the very first blow that
I had she literally was like and I was
like yep this is why I won't do I think
we cut it out I think we cut out the
very first let go of her being like
hitting us up there like I want to be on
it oh yeah be on it I want to be on it
all these people that are like yeah
they're down to like joining it is so
much fun to do and it's so much fun to
us and everyone that we've had has been
so like it is an insane thing to ask
someone to do it be like bottom naked
but we have yeah there's like a blanket
we make sure it's very funny because the
reactions that people are so comical and
but this is you're using it just for
what it's designed for I gotta be honest
with you Elliot installed you can adjust
the like water pressure wall with that
dial I think he just like cranked it off
and broke it it's just incredibly power
turn the knob it'll spray the water will
straightaway powerfully spray like get
there we're like all right but it is
it's a blast I love that show so
literally it is literally a blast yeah I
was gonna say are there any other ideas
like that in the works yes definitely
there are like weird ones that we like
have been like are we gonna challenge
someone to do this yeah you know I
forget where there was one of them it
was a genital mutilation like where do
you go we wanted to do and then like
kind of do like a tick down like you
have to answer these questions oh yeah
yeah similarly in a weird way there's
been a couple other ones but nothing
quite like that's from the mind of Joe
Bereta and that's the most that is the
most Joe Bereta thing ever
every time he's like oh so-and-so said
they do it like I know it's really
surprising who's been eating us up is so
funny because I'm sure the appeal is
like I've never done that before I just
want to feel it once and I wanted
everyone so badly like I can't do
instantly I can't stantly keep being
like holy trinity holy trinity guarantee
that's a hard no from me
I'm gonna try even a trial on our own
like it gave me so much [ __ ] about it
they were like why won't you do it they
were really giving me flak about it I
was like I turned on some people need to
understand this is our actual office
toilet for just that show it is the
toilet we use every day so pray for us
when someone wants to know what a list
actor would you most want to have on
trivia bidet that's really good I know I
keep thinking of like c-list people you
know what I'm gonna say it right now I
god I watched Winter's Bone last night
okay Jennifer Lawrence that was two
hours I can't get back she was nominated
for sure so I'm gonna be honest just has
a pure retribution and revenge
I need Jennifer Lawrence just so I can
be like this is for Winter's Bone okay
I've got to perfect one that's are you
ready for this okay so hang on let me
just okay I've got a guy and a girl who
do you want to hear first girl girl okay
I want what's her name
from the favorite she would just be a
delight and for the guy you guys ready
for this I refuse to accept that this is
not the perfect person okay Jeff
Goldblum yeah perfect that is a big one
actually he works let me talk about
something he's turned on camera yeah
there would be any be so comfortable
with his own yeah
is just have you seen Thor Ragnarok yes
yes just like yeah I just re-watched
again and it's just like every like I
know he'd just you know when the camera
turns off he's still yeah so many that
are like friends with him and weird
whatever and Delmond did a commercial
with him
oh yeah that's year and he lit it was
like it's it's everything you think it
is okay that's every single thing you
think it it's a really great who would
do it in the celebrity like world I
think I mean if it's a press junket most
likely anyone for sure I think depending
on how Holmes and Watson goes we could
probably get welfare I would love to
watch that that one is like people like
it is really funny we we tend to have
wonderful people on there because I feel
like it it's the only way you can do it
if we ever had a serious person on there
would be fully boned because they'd just
be like mall right I know we have really
I mean funny people in our lives because
it's you learn as you go yeah it's also
people genuinely trying to get questions
correct if you're good at trivia don't
even get sprayed my husband did at my
every week dumb and does trivia every
single he's done it and he did like
fantastic and we even tried to stump him
but there was like also he we have
bidets in our home like we have through
the days and it was like Jo sprayed him
and he litter is like so normal it's
really great someone to know what's a
talent that you wish you had dancing I
wish I could play just like been full
because you're already so good at music
and you can I like hear so many things
to you'd be so good at it yeah
yeah that's a good one for you
especially cuz then you could sing along
and be really you'll be so entertaining
I know that's what I want I don't know
Ben Folds level but it's possible to do
that yeah I can't dance it's held me
back so much in my life
he held me back there's there's been
multiple Broadway shows that I was a
fool for and they're just like you
cannot dance I just started taking a
salsa class with a lot of learning on a
dance do salsa dancing cool how's it
going it's pretty it's going pretty well
like do you walk in there with her and
they're like wow that's so sweet this
woman no I got a group home actually I
was I was nervous yeah there are all
types of people there and literally no
one is like that embarrassment of like
am I doing this right
when everyone's paying attention to the
dancer in your own feet like literally I
was in a room alone with Ilana basically
it was great yeah I did one zumba class
with mamrie and I was so wildly off with
them the whole time in the back women
that are like 2 3 oh I couldn't tell my
right from my left and I'm getting so
confused I got in my head so giggly
about it so so and the easiest stuff we
had um Matt steffanina come and teach me
yeah teach us a dance cuz he's a really
great choreographer for our show that we
did last year and I genuinely I was like
okay I'm gonna really I'm gonna try this
I know my limitations but I'm gonna try
and it's still so bad we had to edit
around me just mix up words when they
literally are like we tried I would we
make the move simpler for grace its to
eight counts near like I'm floor and I
don't know what to do Matt steffanina
tried to teach me and and Meg Turney and
trisha hershberger how to do hip hop
dance yeah and it was like no way do i
no way
it was almost confusing to him how he
originally thought that i was like doing
a bit and i was like trying to waste
your time really trying this is a
foreign language and i cannot translate
yeah my daddy yeah I don't know don't
know how to do any of that and then I
get so in my head of like anxiety about
it please don't
so once you know what's the weirdest
prompt your show has ever gotten oh
there was what about like cuz how if you
want to explain for people I don't know
how what your show I mean we it's really
wonderful we take our questions from our
patrons and so that's how you can
actually get a question on the show is
like be a patron and so we take our
questions from our patrons and I mean
Steve said we've said this before we
have are like audience is a funniest
group of people yes so funny they're so
engaging quickly we have so much of the
stuff that they say so they'll have
these prompts that are like genuinely
great like we can never come up with
this stuff it's so good I truly think
the weirdest one though was someone was
like would you rather have leg or legs
sized fingers as legs fingers or finger
sized legs as fingers or something like
that yeah it was like would you rather
have like you'd like your nose leg sized
leg sized arms or arm sized legs yeah I
was something so your legs yeah yeah
yeah your arms line it was like it's
like a math problem I can't there's pre
he was like it was like finger-sized
legs yeah I think it was like leg sized
fingers okay and he was like so your
hands just have these giant legs yeah
legs coming out of every finger was was
like at least you would have the
strength in these giant hands yes would
you have the dexterity I mean I think
you'd learn for strong someone recently
also didn't even put up a prompt they
just put up like a thing where they're
like hey just enough why I eat fried
eggs and a bowl with a spoon it'll
change it'll change your life and where
did they do it thank you but it makes
perfect sense Dairy directors like this
is not a prompt this is a chap and we're
like thank you very much 45:25 Marsha we
got through so much we talked about cats
for just 65 oh my god what is the gifts
for making time you can open it up and
read your fortune Oh Mike this is such a
big deal one I do love a fortune cookie
I did love it I didn't get one one of
Steve's followers does have a connection
to get him into a galaxies edge press
event but they already gave their friend
the path
this isn't really gonna cry you're gonna
see him cry uh-oh
many potential patrons are waiting to
exclusively donate $45,000 target goal
to get Li her lower back Muppet tattoo
your parents credit cards are ready they
go left oh my god Fivey oh no no we just
got them at the store I just say forty
five grand for them up at lower back
what if you got that at an actual
Chinese restaurant like that's the
fortune cookie you got I would lose my
mind yeah I would lose my mind you I
would go and get an animal lower back
tattoo yeah you'd have to his legs go
right above my butt crack the valley
folk you can find us on Twitter and all
that you can google the valley folk just
type the valley folk into all the social
medias no you should start in my opinion
watching your show I love that thing
it's our beast and yeah yeah people like
it playing you guys on social media I'm
at Steve Zaragoza on all the socials I'm
at Lee Newton on instagram at lien it
says on Twitter absolutely wonderful I
will see you guys next episode not too
deep good bye bye 2deep 2deep 2deep
2deep not too deep is a production of
grace helbig incorporated producer and
edited by melissa demons writing by
diane kang a production assistants by
Katrina Henning post production sound by
Chris Henry and an extra special thanks
to Flula for the theme music
[Music]